welcome to designing in the browser in
this series they explore how to take a
design build it and then tweak it in the
browser using the latest and left
technology and design systems today
we're going to take a look at how to
build a layout that scales across mobile
and desktop views that's right we're
talking responsive design and how to
make existing components work in the
context you intend there's so much talk
about so let's dive in size based media
queries are the first tool we have for
responsive design you write media
queries in CSS with the at meteor rule
we usually want to design mobile first
so we think of our smaller screen styles
as being the baseline and then use me
the Aquarius based on our browser's
minimum width to adjust for larger
screen sizes here's a demo with that
image list that we saw in previous
episodes and what I want to show you
here is this device panel so you can
toggle it on and off by clicking on this
little icon here with the two devices
and inside of that we have a variety of
options we have a responsive sort of
option view where we can open and close
this horizontally to see what it looks
like it various screen sizes we also
have shortcuts with various devices you
can swap the view from horizontal to
vertical and vice versa you can really
see a lot of various options for default
styles and again you can make customized
layouts and sizes I'm using this
responsive view or even adding it as one
of your own defaults we'll go through
some of these dev tools more in the next
episode but this is definitely one of
the ones that I use the most let's do a
quick look at that code on this as well
so here we have from the most baseline
position the default which is one column
and no padding between then as we get a
little bit bigger I 500 pixels that goes
to two columns with eight pixels in
between at 800 pixels it goes to three
columns 16 pixels in between as the
margin between those images and so on it
gets bigger so here we have an example
of responsive design across browsers
starting from a baseline of mobile and
getting thicker as the device changes in
size media queries are not just for the
size of the device that you're in
they can also detect the device aspect
ratio pixel density print mode
orientation and a lot more there are
also many new accessibility features
which detect user settings that can now
be accessed as media queries
these include prefers contrast prefers
reduced motion prefers color scheme and
prefers reduced transparency these
features are new to the web with the
latest version of media queries but they
point to this much more responsible
responsive design that we see in the
future those are all super cool and
important to know about when designing
responsibly but for now let's get back
to layout you might not always need
media queries when styling layouts there
are a few CSS properties that will
automatically calculate changes and
apply them based on the width or height
of the browser eliminating the need for
media queries for example the Flex box
and grid layout properties have
calculable properties and auto placement
modes flex box is a layout algorithm
designed to allow elements to stretch or
shrink and best feel the specified
available space based on their intrinsic
size and the context within which they
live flex layouts can be both horizontal
and vertical they'll stay in the single
line by default but can also wrap to
fill the space alignment is an important
concept within flex box too I'll show
you what that looks like right now first
I'm going to give us a little bit of
height so maybe 600 pixels so there's a
little bit more space and you can see
that these are automatically stretching
to fill that space so in order to adjust
that I can use the align items property
and maybe I want to start from center
here I'm aligning the items at the
center you can also align them at the
Flex and the Flex start or anywhere in
between there's a shortcut inside of
google chrome where when you start
typing a property value it autocompletes
your options so you can actually just go
through this list and see what your
options are in terms of alignment
justification is another important
concept so you can justify the content
in the same way that you align the
content with justification like
alignment you could just wear these
items live inside of its parent
container but with justification because
this
is horizontal by default this is going
to align the items within that
horizontal space so say I want to
justify them as space between this
aligns the elements with the space in
between each other there's also a few
different properties that we can play
with here there's space evenly to space
them all evenly centered inside of that
horizontal row there Center which will
just shrink them all together since
there's no margin around these items and
just like the other property of
alignment there is an auto completed
list which you can sort of just go
through and see what your intended
visualization is and your Intendant
effect is with flexbox properties we can
start building more flexible and
responsive designs items will shrink and
stretch and change position without the
need for media queries here's an example
where all that is tied together a
responsive layout with no media queries
all using flexbox here's what it looks
like I have the header section I have a
left sidebar I have a section of these
cards and another sidebar as well as a
footer and if I open up this device
panel you can see that with this
responsive device I have all of these
views visible as I resize this the items
are shrinking if it the space and when
it hits a point when there flex ices
don't fit it will then be pulled over to
the next row this is using the Flex wrap
property where it's going to wrap onto
the next row as I continue to resize
this layout will actually adjust itself
by adjusting the sidebars being next to
each other underneath the card block so
we have multiple points in which flex
box is creating adjustments
independently of elements throughout
this page which is really cool it's kind
of like creating a micro layout within
your page without even needing media
queries however the real wins happen
when you combine these technologies you
can can combine media queries the Flex
box and you can also combine these with
another technology called CSS grid CSS
grid is the newest layout algorithm with
support across all evergreen browsers
it's super powerful and unlike Flex box
provides a structure both vertically and
horizontally at the same time for an
entire page or elements
the way a basic grid works is you
explicitly specify a grid template and
define how many columns grid template
columns and rows grid template rows are
in a grid and then place its children
into the grid using grid column in a
grid row you can also use the auto
keyword when defining this template to
automatically fill children into a grid
we'll go over that a bit more as we
highlight just how powerful and
responsive CSS grids can be here's an
example of placing elements into a grid
so in the HTML we see we just have a
bunch of these little boxes inside of
this body here and so that's what we're
seeing appear on the right in our code
and if I resize this you can see that
these are actually adjusting based on
the CSS that I've written so the first
two columns are not moving and that
middle column is getting wider and
narrower and then at a slower rate that
column all the way to the right with the
4 and the 8 is also decreasing in size
so the screen size gets smaller and
increasing as it gets bigger now let's
look at the code there so here in the
body we have display grid and that's
what's allowing us to create these
columns and rows inside of it we've
created these columns where the first
two columns that's going to be right
here one five nine and two six ten this
is 200 pixels wide and 100 pixels wide
then this area right here with a three
and the seven is getting an auto fit so
it's automatically taking up the
existing rest of the space and then 25%
of the width is what the four and the
eight are doing inside of that column
with that boxes doing so that's where we
get this sort of experience in the UI as
we adjust the sizing we're explicitly
setting the grid and as I mentioned
earlier grid is not just horizontal but
it's also vertical so you can specify
how the rows look as well so here I have
this grid template rows room setting up
the row template and so this first row
is 25% the second row is a hundred
pixels so I'm setting that specifically
and then we have this auto on the bottom
row and that auto is the most narrow
here because it's just letting the
content inside of it dictate how big it
is so we could change these values if I
made this 200 you see that would quickly
adjust here and that would be a much
higher
taller section there we can increase
percentages we can use various unit
types and we can also use justify
content and align items within the grid
just like you can do with the Flex box
I'm doing that right here within the
boxes to Center the numbers inside of
them so that's why as I change sizes
this five six seven eight they remain
vertically and horizontally centered I'm
using a display grid within the box and
I'm setting justified content center and
a line-item Center so it works the same
properties that we have with Flex box we
can use in grid you can also setup your
grid as named grid areas I love using
emoji for this as they can represent a
lot of information in one visual square
unit so here's what that can look like
in the HTML here we only have four boxes
which I'm going to be placing with grid
named areas and you can see as I resize
this they also adjust in their size
based on the width of the container
which is the body in this case so if we
go into the CSS we see that we have
display grid on the body
we also are naming these template areas
one thing I forgot to mention in the
last demo is this grid gap gap allows us
to create spacing between elements so
you aren't hacking around having margins
and removing margins for the first and
last elements and the ones on the right
and left sides this is true gap which is
great because it's a feature that I've
been hacking on for years so now we can
truly have gap I can also increase the
size this gap so you could see where
it's adjusting only between those
elements but let's stick to ten for the
sake of this demo so next we have these
grid template areas and here I'm setting
this entire first row to be just the
header then the second row we have the
main content taking up three-quarters of
the space the sidebar taking up 1/4 of
the space and the footer taking up the
entire bottom when I'm placing these
boxes into these named areas I use grid
area so for box one the grid area is
header for box - that's main for box 3
that's the sidebar here and then for box
4 that's the footer so the way that
these are readjusting is based on the
fractional units of space that are left
in this grid layout for them to be
filled within
but we can specify that space so we want
that sidebar in the right to be a fixed
value maybe we want it to be 150 pixels
then we can create a grid template
column so we can have both grid template
areas and a grid template column so here
I'm going to write grid template columns
and I'm going to specify here maybe I
want this one fractional unit for those
first three and then 150 pixels for that
sidebar so now as I'm resizing this page
the sidebar there the third box remains
fixed but the other content is still
resizing in those fractional units
there's a shortcut that also shipped
with grid that's the repeat function so
instead of writing one fr three times I
can write repeat three one fr and we get
the same result here so I'm just simply
short handing this if you have a lot of
items in your grid maybe you have like a
twelve by grid where you specify each
column and you have things flowing into
multiple columns like I have here with
the footer header in main that really
makes it a lot easier to write out these
grid templates with this little shortcut
so we can also write out the rows so I
can write grid template rows and then
here I'm going to maybe make this Auto
300 pixels and 100 pixels just to give
it some dimension so you could see how
it's shifting in the space we've now
given some physical fixed space for that
main area and sidebar in the footer and
then this header is taking the auto of
the content within it the automatic
spacing which is just right above this
text value itself finally we can make
this look a little bit neater by using a
single unit value so instead of writing
header I'm just going to command D to
select all these I can use a shorthand
like H for main I'm just going to use
letter M for sidebar I'm just gonna use
an S and then for footer here I'm going
to select this all and use an F and this
makes it really easy to see the entire
grid and how its laid out and I think a
fun way to do this also is to use emoji
so if I select right here I'm just using
the command tool to select all the same
time I'm gonna hit backspace and then
open up my emoji panel here maybe I want
to select a shoe
to represent footer so here I have an
ice skate to represent the footer so
this totally works and it's just a fun
way to really represent the space that
is really clear like what you're looking
at it kind of gives you this mental
shorthand maybe I want my main space to
be what you're you know looking at most
continent so the Tut out why not the
sidebar we could use arrows for this too
so I could use an arrow that points out
so it's like over here on the side and
then for the header why not just use a
little smiley right there I set selected
all of these I'm opening up this
template panel and there we go smiley
face is my header so you can use moji in
your CSS I think it works particularly
well in grid because these are sort of
single unit values that represent a lot
of information and it's a little bit
more clear than just letters which you
can forget what they mean they could
overwrite other meanings so I like
seeing it all sort of laid out like this
grant introduces a few new interesting
capabilities that gives even more
options for building responsive designs
here's an example of creating a
responsive grid without the use of media
queries like the example of flexbox that
media creates in this demo we're using
the autofill keyboard with a min/max
function to create responsive boxes we
have ten boxes here placed within the
body which is where we're going to be
creating our grid again and so if we
look at the CSS there you can see that
we have this grid template columns but
we're using this autofill and a min/max
function here when I resize this page
you can see that these items are
stretching until they hit a certain
point and then they break to then
display at a smaller size but with more
items within that row and so what we're
doing here is we're in these columns
specifying that the minimum size of
these elements is 250 pixels I want to
get smaller than that to break and then
fill that space one fractional unit of
the remaining space so if it hits 250
then we can add more items on the page
and see it's same 215 we can now have
three items horizontally on the page
within that row so this is really cool
because you are getting this
responsiveness automatically if I change
this minimum size 200 pixels you'll see
that more
quickly we're filling up that space as
we resize these values now what autofill
does here is it fills the row with as
many columns as it can't if they take up
less space and allotted then you'll see
where that ends so if I make this a much
smaller value say we set that to 40
pixels as I stretch this out you'll see
that there is space on the right that
it's not filling in but if I change this
to autofit what's going to happen is
that's actually going to stretch to fill
the space regardless of what size that
container is because we're telling it to
stretch out autofit fits the columns
into the row by stretching them so that
they take up the full available space of
the row so this would be like if you
applied the Flex property flex one to
each of these children's that they would
stretch to fit the space media queries
again can be very useful when making
multiple changes on a page but flex and
grid can provide their own macro and
micro layout systems that are just
algorithmically and apart from specified
media queries media queries do now go
far beyond sizing alone I want to show
you an example of using the prefers
color scheme media query to showcase a
dark theme on the web in a previous
episode we talked about using custom
properties for theming and we can use
those same concepts and update those
custom properties based on media queries
so remember this data tables demo where
we have a data table example this layout
so inside of our code instead of
adjusting these properties with Java
Script I'm going to write a media query
that says at media prefers color scheme
dark and so here were updating the route
properties just based on this preferred
color scheme so what does that look like
well right now we're seeing this light
theme but if I go into my system
preferences on my computer it's in
general I can change the appearance to
dark and doing that will automatically
change the color scheme here to the dark
theme and so we can do this all inside
of our CSS I've set up this media query
here based on the color scheme
preference responsive layouts help us
build applications with user experiences
more tailored to our customers devices
and personalized needs I hope today's
show helps you discover some of the ways
that we can lay out our applications and
how responsive design extends past
screen size alone what are your favorite
responsive experiences or what do you
hope to see more of as technology gets
more and more advanced on the web leave
a comment below we'd love to hear what
you think until next time
[Music]